Paul:
Be me for a second. Would you
trust you?
The answer is no.
-Ahh!
-(Screaming)
Well, you didn’t let me be you.
Here.
Jimmy, sorry for always being so
hard on ya, it’s only cause I
love ya.
I don’t talk like that.
When Harrison said that he would
do it
and I saw the announcement
I thought it was a practical
joke.
It seemed unreal that you wanted
to do this show with me.
Oh, man, come on.
No, it’s really true and I’m
sure at some point, this is my
every day.
♪I'm on the pursuit of
happiness, and I know♪
Sit down, Jimmy.
If I sit down, I’m going to feel
like I’m in trouble.
You are in trouble!
They wanted John Wayne but they
were disappointed to hear about
his demise.
(Laughing)
Do you know who the most
important person in your life is
right now?
You.
No, you sh..head, your daughter!
Right, that’s what I meant.
I’m second.
Okay.
In all seriousness, I’ve always
admired his work.
The writing is fantastic and the
relationship is to me really
funny and interesting.
He doesn’t think so but I do.
(Laughing)
Could we talk?
I don’t need another lecture.
It’s about Gabby.
Oh, I was kinda looking forward
to a fight.
Yeah, I could tell.
These two guys, they have a
mentor-mentee relationship,
but I think it’s also a
surrogate father-son
relationship.
Jimmy desperately wants Paul’s
approval.
You just said you love me.
No, I did not!
Well, it sounded like you did.
Oh...
Jason Segel:
I think Paul has a really
complicated relationship with his kids
and sees Jimmy as potentially a
son so the show is all about
lines being blurred
and I think that the Paul-Jimmy
relationship is a real example
of that.
I’ve known you for years, I’ve
never met your daughter.
Yeah, what is she like?
She lives in Connecticut.
Wow. It’s like she’s in the
room.
The character that Jason plays
is complex and uh, visceral and
exciting.
Harrison Ford:
The relationship comes from the
writers
but there also is a personal
relationship that, that fuels
me.
Who knows how you grieve?
You haven’t even begun.
What are you talking about?
I’ve been grieving for a year
No, you’ve been numbing.
Paul:
I’m worried about you.
Harrison Ford:
It’s the kind of material where
I don’t know if from one moment to the next
whether I'm going to laugh or
cry.
I feel enormously lucky to
just be part of this thing.
Jason Segel:
Same.
Harrison Ford
And, I think it’s good for
people to laugh.
You should see Harrison Ford do
comedy.
Not today.
No, not today.
(Laughing)
Do you know what percentage of
yourself is actually made of
water?
I know what percentage of me
doesn’t give a sh..
Ok, well, that’s the dehydration
talking.